[Music]  warming Thermage whisper as they rise to  tell us they are soon to bring to view  in cool air and aloft before your eyes a  gentle wisp to counterpoint the blue  powder puffs emerged to grant her grace  that further bloomers would force daily  tree and you'll a site that calls for  our embrace another cloud anew above the  leaf cruising forth she yearns for  ageless life for how her hopes will soon  be dashed it made  for up there in the cold she caught a  strife to fade away as drops of clothing  rain scant  and lacy speak her live expand fair  among us could be brought to mourn when  she was there to populate her clan for  the Fallen Tina's new daughters  [Music]